c'est l'un des plus beaux palmarès de la
natation française camille lacourt était
ce mardi 7 septembre au golf de la
boulie à versailles les sportifs est
venu partager son expérience auprès
d'évelyne business club à un réseau de
dirigeants à l'univers dans lequel il
s'est plongé après sa retraite en 2017
qu'est ce que je vais leur dire je vais
leur dire ce que moi j'ai fait bien ce
que j'aurais pu faire de mieux ce que
j'ai fait de moins bien est ce que
j'aurais dû faire bien et après voilà en
essayant de leur donner des clés pour la
gestion du stress sur les objectifs sur
sur la compétitivité et après à eux
d'essayer de prendre quelques éléments
pour pour essayer de les mettre dans
leur entreprise pendant ce rendez-vous
le sportif de deux mètres a raconté son
parcours professionnel ses exploits dans
les différentes piscines du monde la
route a été belle le chemin a été à a
été semée d'embûches mais de d'émotion
extraordinaire avec des gens
extraordinaires des coach des
préparateurs mentaux des préparateurs
physiques des kinés pour rencontrer l'ex
sportif de 36 ans le repas affiche
complet j'avais entendu parler de ces
performances et on le voit à la télé
donc mais sinon rien de plus c'est une
vraie découverte aujourd'hui jamie la
courge c'est un sportif exceptionnel
c'est quelqu'un qui a une aura sportive
incroyable tout le monde le connaît
c'est un champion du monde c'est un
champion olympique ça reste quand même
une personne très connue mondialement
c'est un poisson c'est un poisson dans
les bassins est et on a été nombreux à
vibrer autour de ces différentes
victoires camille lacourt a déjà annoncé
vouloir revenir dans les yvelines à
titre privé cette fois ci pour jouer au
golf